that's it
you crossed the line yeah
so many things to love about these
images the weather being the least of
them uh this was the moment the trio
arrived in antigua yesterday morning
they are abby johnston charlotte irving
and cat cordner a cat has incurable
ovarian cancer they completed that 3 000
mile trip uh yesterday in 42 days seven
hours and 17 minutes as i said beating
the world record by a whole week well
i'm pleased to say the record-breaking
rowers join me now live from antigua
ladies hello
good morning good morning well it looks
glorious where you are and you've got
massive smiles on your faces and it's
not just because of the sunshine and if
i can come to you first abby how on
earth do you break what takes seven days
off a world record that's incredible
i know uh we can't quite believe it
really actually people keep saying to us
that it's the most a record has ever
been beaten by we're not 100 sure if
that's true but um it was hard work
we're not going to lie it was absolutely
brutal we're all exhausted um
but you know worth it when you pop those
flares on the finish line and um
and you hear broken a world record all
that hard work totally worth it well i
know you got a personal message from
camilla the duchess of cornwall wishing
you fair wins and following seas it
seems that um her message had paid off
for you and you've got just that and cat
if i can come to you because a lot is
being made of your incurable ovarian
cancer and people saying not just a
phenomenal effort for all three of you
but for you especially because your big
challenge got to just getting in that
boat talk to me about what happened
before you actually got to pick up the
oars
uh yeah so yeah you're right i had so
cervical cancer that i i have um and
after being remission it came back so
yeah i went through a lot of
chemotherapy
uh then six weeks of radiation daily
radiotherapy and also found out in the
interim that i had a
cardiac tumor to throw in so i had to
have heart surgery as well so it was
only sort of may last year really where
i then could start training um so yeah
i'm i'm just glad that i got to start
the race to be honest and obviously
ecstatic that i've managed to finish it
yeah cat your big challenge as i said
before you got in the boat and then you
completed this incredible challenge as i
said uh breaking a world record and
charlotte it wasn't all hard work on the
boat because i've seen your social media
feeds you had time for dancing he had
what looked like a hawaiian theme night
with was that cocktails
cocktails no it was a very small bottle
of champagne we took but um i think when
it's a challenge like this that's so
long it's important to have balance so
you know we work hard really hard but we
also kind of played hard as well to an
extent as much as you can on a 23-foot
boat but um yeah we you know you find
joy where you can so having fun fridays
where you know you wear a hawaiian shirt
making the most of new year's eve cat's
birthday just got to kind of um
celebrate the good times to kind of try
and get you through the bad so yeah we
did have we had fun out there all three
of us and we've come back still fast
friends which was a huge objective for
us as well so it wasn't just about the
record it was about just enjoying the
whole experience so we're so glad we got
to do that as well yeah um abby
incredible highs but incredible lows as
well because it's 42 days in a boat
experiencing all kind of conditions talk
to me a little bit about that and
importantly
why you undertook this challenge in the
beginning because it was to raise money
wasn't it
yeah so um
yeah there were definitely some low
points you know i know in the first few
weeks i was just absolutely exhausted
and i think everybody gets to land and
it's like oh my god it's amazing
life-changing best thing we've ever done
and nobody's ever like but it's so hard
um you know so there were we because
we're a trio it was actually sort of
even harder for us because we'd row for
two hours and then we'd only get one
hour rest whereas teams of four could do
two on two off and so we were just
really struggling lack of sleep you know
and we were hallucinating at various
points cats thought she saw this massive
whale tale um she didn't
so so exhaustion and
and and then i guess the why forever for
all of us it's probably a bit different
you know cats y is is probably a bit
more um poignant than ours but
why not you know i think you have to do
these things in life like nobody can
appreciate dry land like we can right
now and you know you push yourselves to
the limits and
realize what you're made of really i'm
not saying i'll do it again but you know
this feeling is pretty good oh well abby
charlotte and kat congratulations go now
relax on the beach have one of those
cocktails you've only had a small bottle
of champagne on that entire row so go
and enjoy yourselves and well done and
raising incredible amounts of money for
fantastic causes thank you so much for
joining us ladies